[Music]
and take my place bro news oh yeah
submitted by argh matey
like I just spoke instead of art I could
have yeah but I'm 80
I'm not his monkey an inmate is being
accused of drugging his twin brother and
swapping places with him to escape jail
so the other twin has to go inside it's
an actual doings in real life that's
[ __ ] crazy that's crazy can't trust
nobody can't trust them I think I would
be the nice twin really yeah you're the
guy you're the twin you thinks you're
the nice man but you're not and I think
I would I wouldn't be the evil twin what
is that twins
stop him though I thought they had that
like telekinesis well they can kind of
finish each other sentences yeah so they
should be able to feel weight my twin is
trying to drug me in trade places and
stop the [ __ ] right well that's
why how he got in there he used the twin
bridge connection which is medical do
girls have fantasies of having a
threesome with two with twins
yes do you want to [ __ ] to Joe's maybe
not to Joe's but to guys we've done with
that call you'd be down you know you
want to [ __ ] Japanese sausages in you
in one hole or a different hole oh the
girl has two dicks together like this
yeah
yeah do it go get two why would you need
this this is the [ __ ] vagina I'm
trying to show you something now is okay
don't do this they get two dicks
together you never seen that very - very
secure guys who are bros forever they
press them together like bends to the
left or something B press I've never
seen it nice to the left to the right
[Laughter]
they can just both be straight through
this I don't like that kind of porn -
it's like a [ __ ] magic trick to me I
agree it just makes me like think that
there's unrealistic expectations ass
[ __ ] wizard sleeve vagina out of here
no this is just a standard accurate
vagina
yeah size to scale if that [ __ ] was a
standard size then it would have
probably been a breeze for Gio to pop
out like oh I know I just came right
what the [ __ ] will be putt tiger pop out
tiger try to say that fast everyone can
say it fast do it with your nose closed
he's just trying to [ __ ] cuz I got
boogers she's stupid
all right well I explains a lot thank
you so this man here from Peru his name
is Alexander he's serving a 16-year
sentence for child abuse child sexual
abuse what'd he do [ __ ] kids yeah child
sexual abuse and robbery what a piece of
[ __ ] are you gonna [ __ ] a burglar and
[ __ ] kids
that's a weird resumes that is it
doesn't it's like two different things
yeah that's like [ __ ] mass murderer
and [ __ ] like stock trader
embezzlers and like were you there to
burgle where were you there to [ __ ] kids
is my whole thing yeah did you come in
to steal the thing to steal a TV or did
you come in for the other reason and if
you apply for a gang and you have those
things on your resume
like which one are red flags right
you're like all burglar we need that guy
and then there's a kid [ __ ] and you're
like wait a sec I have to take this over
to HR cuz I don't know about that yeah
we all we all like those kinds do have
HR now which i think is great yeah it's
about time
and the unionize so yeah PR team and
everything yeah yeah yeah they're
getting preyed upon so they need backups
yeah so what he did is during a visit
from his twin Alexander he ended up
drugging his brother changed into his
clothes and then just strolled out of
the prison was a [ __ ] fiberglass
thing where they put their hands against
each other well this isn't even that
general meeting area for the
non-violence so it's just like a [ __ ]
chicken cage or something there's guards
in there I don't they had that [ __ ] with
the phone and they could talk about
anything in the phone but in the night
up though they were able to meet in
person and that's how he was like able
to like take all the jobs like the
general but you're not supposed to touch
or anything you just sit across at a
table
yeah how do you switch Chloe you meet
this isn't Peru dad they might not have
the same thing / oh yeah they might just
be open individual Martin Peruvian he
can explain it yeah depending on the
crime sometimes you meet and like a
little goat fence and then you guys can
do whatever you want there and then
sometimes you meet where it's you add a
what are those maracas factory they
can't afford walls and [ __ ] can I just
ask how can they talk to each other at
the maracas factory because of the
sounds of the malicious region a dialect
it cuts right through it it's a
different type of Spanish coz there's
the right my understanding is that the
way when they come down the conveyor
belt it's very loud especially if they
don't have the special rubber pad it's
not authentic it's made in Mexico yeah
that one's a fake one take maracas no
they're supposedly come from Mexico or
do they I believe anything because I
know nothing about it what is this no is
this a corporator
tell me that maracas came from Alabama
and I beg really and then I guess they
do yeah I like it it's like a baby
rattle yeah well according to Google
maracas come from Colombia Venezuela
Brazil by the way exactly really when
it's fake export to all the countries
around that those guys are just a
distributors I understand my bet yeah
okay looks like an idiot again they
would say that the iPhone came from
California the state's obvious but it's
actually made in China today which comes
from China so the Peru is the actual
place where the maracas were born that's
true school so yeah back to this twin uh
so they finally figure it out when they
did they cross reference fingerprints so
they took the twin brothers fingerprints
and then they looked at who the inmate
originally was and they found out like
oh [ __ ] he switched places of this twin
but apparently I don't know if he has
been so funny that they didn't even work
together on this if they were [ __ ]
getting chased by a lion just pushes
bird into the line yeah what do they do
now do they keep that twin in until the
other one comes back or do they let that
twin go because he didn't commit any
crimes and now both twins are on the
loose so he drugged his brother right he
drugged him and then his brother wakes
up he's like yo my twin drug me in anime
believable and they're like yeah right
shut up but see that's what's so weird
is in this case I'd be like oh let's
look into something about this real
quick cuz he does have an identical twin
I don't know they fingerprinted and then
they go oh yeah yeah you're telling
truth that's that's what happened right
yeah but um but if they let this twin
out this would be a good case where
other twins can now figure out a way to
bail the other two enough because all
you have to do is get the innocent twin
in there and now they have to let the
other innocent or not and both twins are
free so make a good scam yeah
that rap group called twins no no 20s
cut to summer go around and round watch
look they're twins called the twins no I
did want to let you guys know that that
Alexandre was on the run for thirteen
months until he was arrested so they did
arrest him and they also kept his
brother on suspicion of collaborating
with his yes I'm thinking yeah but then
they later released him so he's fine oh
okay yeah you couldn't get [ __ ] on him I
guess yeah and then they're saying that
the reason why Alexander broke out was
because he was desperate to see his
mother Levi well cuz she won't visit him
what a [ __ ] shitty ass mom that's true
anybody with robbery and child [ __ ] on
the resume do mr. mom's that's very true
that's funny that would be true so his
mom won't visit him because he was kid
[ __ ] him I know right anybody he breaks
out of prison and he goes and visits her
I will never talk to my I would never
talk to my kid again well my kid was a
criminal yeah I talked to him you will
it hurt - well depends on yeah it don't
matter
my jeans are godly so they're allowed to
do whatever they want about that yeah
what's godly about what's godly about
you so whatever my kid does it's not her
face is like this get alone of the horse
[ __ ] that's about the cover we're immune
to the law there I said it okay
because what's godly value like like
like genetically so that's why if
anything happens around your [ __ ]
question what's the what's the goddamn
heart
I'm from the master race no no I know I
can even agree I'm John Mallia what the
[ __ ] but can you bleed like can you like
lay do you guys have some enzyme we you
can eat anything you want like how's it
work no we just
have genetic immunity to loss see I was
hoping that this would be a vast ocean
of depth that you finally get to talk
about your guide you but I've reached my
hand in the pot and I wrote a very
shallow pot don't dive into it hey
suppose we had first at first no you'll
die
you know why they say I sign as a genius
it's because he could simplify
everything to where normal people can
understand but no one can understand
this it's amplified you're funny jazz I
like you
[Music]
[Music]
you